نجحت القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه في تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه استهدفت
سفينه حاويات ميرسك هانغزو كانت متجهه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله وذلك بصواريخ بحريه
مناسبه اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه تعلن شن جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين هجوما على سفينه شحن تابعه لشركه
ميرسك ومروحيات للبحريه الامريكيه جنوب
البحر الاحمر وتقول انها ردت باغراق ثلاثه
زوارق للمهاجمين ميرسك اعلنت تعليق ابحار
سفنها في البحر الاحمر ووزير الدفاع
البريطاني يؤكد ان هذه الهجمات تضاعفت خمس
مرات خلال الشهرين الاخيرين تجدون المزيد
من اخبار حرب غزه في الرابط الموجود في
التعليق الاول قوات النظام السوري تستهدف
بقصف مدفعي سوقا شعبيا وسط مدينه ادلب ما
ادى الى مقتل مدنيين واصابه 16 اخرين
بينهم اربعه اطفال بجروح خطيره في حين وثق
التقرير السنوي للدفاع المدني السوري مقتل
162 مدنيا بينهم 46 طفلا بسبب هجمات
النظام السوري وروسيا على الشمال السوري
خلال عام
2023 روسيا تتوعد اوكرانيا ض على هجوم
استهدف مدينه بيلغورد واسفر عن مقتل اكثر
من 20 شخصا مؤكده انه لن يمر دون عقاب
وذلك خلال اجتماع طارئ لمجلس الامن الدولي
في نيويورك حيث اتهمت موسكو كيف بارتكاب
ما وصفته بالعمل الارهابي المتعمد
وباستخدام ذخائر عنقوديه لضرب
بالجر الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
توافق بالاجماع على ضم بلغاريا ورومانيا
جزئ
الى منطقه شنغن الاوروبيه اعتبارا من
الحادي من شهر مارس عام
2024 ورفع القيود على الحدود الجويه
والبحريه للبلدين رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه رحبت بالقرار مؤكده ان توسيع
حدود الشينغن يجعل الاتحاد اقوى داخليا
وعلى المسرح
العالمي الى
اللقاء l